ja guten morgen liebe fußballfans auch
von meiner seite hier heißt es jetzt an
dieser stelle achtung you'll never walk
alone und damit sage ich good morning
liverpool good morning jürgen klopp
können sie uns sehen und hören hallo
kann ich guten morgen wie fühlt er sich
an recht wie fühlt es sich an als
tabellenführer herr klopp die kollegen
ganz klar angesprochen burnley 2 0
geschlagen nach zwei spieltagen auf
platz eins mehr geht doch nicht ach
ja mehr geht tatsächlich nicht wir sind
gerne schon angekommen sozusagen eins
ist natürlich alles früheren wir haben
unseren schlaf bis hierhin ganz
ordentlich absolviert aber ja natürlich
auch nicht mehr das weiß natürlich auch
jeder und ich habe gerade ja schon ein
bisschen zu anderen beiden kollegen als
ich sie hat gesagt leicht und locker
gegen berlin gewonnen das geht nicht das
widerspricht sich man kann gegen burnley
nicht leicht und locker gewinnen weil
boerne einem alles abverlangt und das
waren super intensives spiel aber wir
haben sehr gut gemacht und war aus sicht
eines der besten spiele die wir bisher
gegen bern absolviert haben auch wenn
man schon mal höher gewonnen haben wenn
es so gut kontrolliert wie man es
kontrollieren kann und das ist wichtiger
und das ist ganz früh in der saison wir
müssen ein paar morgenstern und deswegen
auch das auch so früh schon wieder ein
bisschen umstellen aber
alles gut bis dahin nichts zu meckern er
klopft bevor er jetzt noch weiter
sportlich werden gleich kurze frage wie
sieht der typische club family
sonntagvormittag aus wenn bild live
nicht gerade dazwischenfunkt ich habe
keine sonder vormittage normalerweise
bei ich bin am trainingsgelände weil wir
haben heute morgen natürlich training
bin hier schon seit über
einer stunde und um 11 uhr ist dann
training also unsere zeit 11 wo ist dein
training und ja danach ist dann auch ein
paar dinge zu tun also der freitag in
einer normalen woche was wir
normalerweise nicht haben aber die
nächste ist normale ist dann der montag
ich also habe also zusammen mit den
friseuren frei sozusagen
und was machen sie dann an so einem
montagmorgen wie sie der pole aus können
sie vor die tür gehen ja ja aber das
sagt da kann ich gleich vor die tür
gehen aber nicht nach liverpool sondern
da wo ich wohne gleich vor die tür gehen
der hund muss hier raus ja wenn es sich
ergibt ein bisschen sport machen und
ansonsten den rest der woche vorbereiten
also wer sie sind ja ganz bisschen
saison ich habe nicht das gefühl dass
wir jetzt schon gedanken müsste wie
könig im freien tag irgendwie sehr
sinnvoll nutzen alles gut zu ende also
club und der hund müssen raus am montag
herz sprechen wir aber erstmal ein
bisschen über fußball hat klopp wir
schauen sehr neidisch auf die bilder in
der premier league auch gestern bei
ihrem spiel in burley mehr als 50.000
zuschauer an der anfield road diese
unvergleichliche stimmung wie fühlt es
sich für sie anja die zuschauer wieder
bei ihnen zu haben im stadion
außergewöhnlich großartig es ist ganz
schwierig über das was im moment zu
sprechen weil man der welt also wenn man
so lange nicht gehabt es war glaubt 529
tage bei uns und das ist natürlich eine
extrem lange zeit und ich niemals
gedacht dass ich so lange auf das
verzichten muss als aber das letzte mal
schwer darüber zu sprechen wenn auch
kein mensch weiß wie lange das dir zu
bleiben wir hoffen und beten alle dafür
dass es jetzt einfach das war der start
und jetzt soll es dann endlich auch so
bleiben dass sich die situation
im land weit europaweit weltweit
hoffentlich schritt für schritt ein
bisschen normalisiert dass man
eigentlich solche bilder nicht nur aus
englischen stadien sieht und man kann
deutlich sagen wir waren gestern alle
extrem emotional bei der ganzen
geschichte also es gab momente wo es
wirklich also meine familie war ja da
man berate aber auch da und alle haben
davon gesprochen dass einfach das gab
momente wurden wo man die tränen nur
schwer zurückhalten konnte und wir
wissen alles ist nur fußball aber man
hat so lange nicht gehabt und es ist
offensichtlich so viel partner so viel
emotionalität hier drin da war es schon
moment da wurde so gedacht oh mein gott
das schon speziell und es ist nicht nur
dass das salz in der suppe ist weil mir
wahrscheinlich die suppe noch dazu weil
man einfach das spiel ja wirklich nur
richtig richtig genießen kann wenn die
atmosphäre dabei ist und die war gestern
mit sicherheit die beste die wir jemals
bei dem 12 uhr 30 angriff hatten auch
der gemeinde engländer braucht ein
bisschen besser wird deswegen ist die
anstoßzeit nicht die populärste aber
gestern war das richtig gut das heißt da
fällt die extra runde durch den park
voraus für die fans die ins stadion
wollen wenn es um 12.30 losgeht oder
macht sich dann der liverpooler nichts
draus und stößt schon mal um 11 uhr an
das kann nicht wirklich was zu sagen war
ja noch nie um 11 uhr in der früh
morgens und habe geguckt ob die pubs
schon so gut besucht sind es eher so
dass eigentlich glaubt generell menschen
natur ist das wenn man für fußball
gucken ist es irgendwie so ist drei uhr
schon okay halb vier war okay ein
bisschen später und abends spielen sind
wir sonst hat man ganzen tag den sie und
andere die jungs die leute stehen
morgens auf und dann muss man schon mal
so ein bisschen in die gänge kommen aber
wie gesagt gäste war das nicht der fall
erstens von anfang an richtig da herr
klopp weil sie die zuschauer ansprechen
die bedeutung dieser atmosphäre sie
haben ja zwei großartige titel jahre mit
liverpool gehabt erst die champions
league gewonnen dann die premier league
endlich wieder nach liverpool geholt in
der letzten saison keinen titel und das
war genau die saison in der so wenig
zuschauer in den stadien waren wie noch
nie zuvor leidet ein verein wie
liverpool stärker unter diesen
geisterspielen weil einfach auch ihre
spieler und auch sie mit ihrer
emotionalen art wahnsinnig viel kraft
aus den gesängen aus dem dasein der
zuschauer beziehen
das ist möglich aber war letztes jahr
nicht unser größtes problem unser
größtes problem ist dass wir ohne abwehr
spielen mussten
es hilft nicht und das hat man einfach
das wahre lektion probleme als das ist
workshop am tag ausgefallen david hat ja
auch jetzt hatte jeder drüber gesprochen
ist genug berichtet worden aber eben
auch joel matip ausgefallen und so gomez
und ausstand hat mir keinen der
ursprünglichen verteidige mehr zu
verfügung das ist einfach eine weile
gedauert bis wir uns daran müssen wir
damit umgehen konnten wir mussten
mittelfeldspieler zur innenverteidigung
umfunktionieren und dann fehlen sie
allerdings im mittelfeld so dicht unsere
struktur war einfach weg wir konnten das
was wir vorher was wir uns normal war
konnte nicht mehr spielen und das ist
natürlich dann schwierig in so einen
starken liga www die premier league und
dass wir am ende dritter geworden sind
ist definitiv so hoch einzuordnen für
uns das ist doch auch nicht so gesehen
wird ist ja klar das macht ja nichts für
uns ist das so ein ort mit der
meistertitel das ja das buch weil es
absolut ausgeschlossen war eigentlich
dass das noch geht ich habe mit lothar
matthäus
interview gemacht zusammen 60 geburtstag
und da hat er da haben wir darüber
gesprochen ich meine gesagt haben ja mit
der champions league so dass man
realistisch sein das wird nix mehr aber
da haben uns ein bisschen europa league
gekümmert und gehofft dass blade reinke
am ende hat sie zwar ist die chance die
geworden nicht nur vierter sondern
dritter also das war schon sehr speziell
und außergewöhnlich und das gibt uns
schon auch kraft für diese saison das
ist einfach noch mal zu versuchen
absolut gestartet mit 15 0 toren und 27
reden wir mal kurz über die bundesliga
lieber herr klopp sie sind ja ältere
zuschauer werden sich erinnern der
letzte trainer der es geschafft hat dass
der deutsche meister mal nicht bayern
münchen heißt 2012 ist ihm das gelungen
mit borussia dortmund wenn sie sich
jetzt aktuell die bundesliga angucken
sie haben lothar matthäus gerade
angesprochen lothar hat vor der saison
gesagt dortmund hat einen besseren kader
als bayern münchen zum beispiel die
erste elf ist zwar bei bayern immer noch
das maß aller dinge aber über die breite
hat dortmund eine chance wie sehen sie
das ist wirklich dortmund chance ist
jetzt nach 2012 mal wieder zupacken groß
wie nie auch wenn es gestern gegen
freiburg danebenging
groß wie die weiß ich nicht aber sie ist
da und man hat jetzt gemerkt dass
tatsächlich in bayern beide mannschaften
haben noch probleme also auf scheint
technisch noch probleme als es war ja im
supercup zu erkennen glaubt eines hat da
der rechte aus metall bayern gespielt
ich denke mal das war jetzt nicht so
geplant vor der saison haben es waren
doch einige spieler die ein bisschen
angeschlagen waren bei dortmund haben
eine abwehr unglaublich viele spieler
gefehlt die konnten die ganze
vorbereitung ich kann nie zusammen
spielen so also das muss natürlich erst
mal so ein bisschen setzen und so weiter
und da muss man sehen ich weiß nicht
genau ich kenne jetzt auch den bayern
kader nicht außen genau und weiß wer
noch ist aber ich habe immer das gefühl
das gibt auch schon noch etliche
lösungen die diese anbieten aber saison
ist lang und befangen ab dieser lent
nach dieser länderspielpause spielen wir
alle alle drei tage in england auch noch
ein winter durch das jetzt in
deutschland nicht genauso aber jetzt
wird ab jetzt weniger die wirklich
intensive phase los nach dieser
länderspielpause nach der nächsten und
dann muss man sehen dann ist die
kaderbreite jahr gefragt im moment hat
braucht man hier noch gar nicht wirklich
weil wir immer alles nur samstags
samstags samstag gespielt bis nächste
woche und dann das kann man natürlich
auffangen aber ja wahrscheinlich hat
dortmund zunächst einen richtig guten
kader ob er besser ist das kann ich
jetzt wirklich nicht sagen aber er ist
gut genug um in bayern auf jeden fall
probleme zu bereiten und das immer mal
die grundvoraussetzung umlage noch
ranzukommen und wenn man das ist dann
gibt es immer auch die chance
vorbeizuziehen
wir müssen natürlich über einen
dortmunder reden jürgen klopp der hier
ja seit er in der bundesliga ist
eigentlich jeden tag das große thema ist
der norweger sie ahnen schon ling
harland der hier wirklich alle mitreißt
mit seiner unglaublich
leidenschaftlichen art und die eine oder
andere bude macht er ja auch was glauben
sie ist eigentlich schon klar dass der
in der saison
22 23 bei einem premier league klub
auflaufen wird müssen wir uns damit
abfinden dass ist die letzte
bundesliga-saison von diesem wunderbaren
stürmer ist
das weiß ich nicht aber wie gefahr
besteht natürlich präsent
außergewöhnlichen talent der junge ist
ja wirklich eine naturgewalt muss man
sagen ich habe glaube ich ihm was war
das denn das erste spiel wir können
sogar vor bereich weiß ich gar nicht
habe ich ihn beim torjubel gesehen hatte
ein ball auf den boden geholt da war ich
mir nicht sicher ob der ob dann nicht in
der delle ebenso holten ist also das ist
natürlich wirklich sehr sehr spannender
spieler der wirklich spaß macht beim
zugucken gerne ganz schnell ganz eigene
energie entwickelt und das ist da wird
oder kurz oder lang bei den großen
vereinen im gespräch seien wäre es nicht
schon ist und dann muss man sehen was
rbb hat mit der dortmunder gegen halten
kann aber ich glaube ich war aber ich
weiß nicht ob das nächstes jahr schon
der fall sein wird oder nicht keine
ahnung aber auf jeden fall ein toller
spieler der wirklich spaß macht
zuzugucken haben sie schon mal mit der
whatsapp vorgefühlt und leicht
norwegisch gelernt wie ein bisschen
schon mal an liverpool run zu füttern
oder wie geht man so was an wenn so ein
top mann plötzlich die bundesliga kurz
und klein schießt
er habe gut also ich hab sein wenn man
nicht wahrscheinlich dass leichte dass
er meine rausfindet weil die haben
überraschend viele leute als dass ich
seine rauskriegen würde aber so läuft
das natürlich nicht das müsste man dann
wahrscheinlich müsste man benimmt den
berater kontaktieren und hätten sie
gerne geglaubt hätten sie gerne in
liverpool
also jetzt im moment ja ist einfach da
ist einfach ein ganz ein ganz
interessanter spieler das muss man das
sagen und will mich wenn ich mag die
energie die auf den platz bringt das mag
ich wirklich ab ob dafür überhaupt in
frage kommt ist immer ist da siehst du
das weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ist
nicht so wichtig aber ich glaube dass in
england mal so generell den meisten
mannschaften ziemlich gut zu gesicht
stehen würde sie haben sich angesprochen
die energie die er mitbringt das ist
natürlich mittlerweile denkt man da
immer sofort an anfield road ja viel
energie im stadion dieser wille diese
dynamik unglaublich wie er sich auch
ärgert gegentore fallen nicht weiß nicht
ob sie das beim supercup verfolgt haben
am dienstag bei der niederlage gegen
bayern jedes mal wenn dann bayern tor
fiel da konnte man in seinem gesicht
wirklich lesen was da gerade an frust
und enttäuschung abgeht
er ist ein ehrgeiziger junger der ist
nachvollziehbar ab so nachvollziehbar
aber meistens situation das war schon
immer so wenn hinten vorfeld wurde vorn
beim verteidigen oft schon was falsch
gemacht hat sollte vielleicht einmal
kurz sich auch in solchen search hoch
damit beschäftigen weil er ist noch jung
genug und hat noch viel potenzial da bin
ich mir ganz sicher um in allen aspekten
des spiels sich noch zu verbessern herr
klopp wenn sie mal kurz grundsätzlich
auf dem transfermarkt schauen liverpool
steht da auf platz 41 in europa derzeit
was die ausgaben in dieser saison
betrifft also große zurückhaltung bis
auf konrad von leipzig haben sie da noch
nicht zugeschlagen gleichzeitig sehen
wir aber wie die vereine manchester city
und paris ja die lass uns noch mal
richtig krachen und zeigen allen wo
finanziell der hammer gerade hängt
corona hin oder her wenn der scheiche
sprudeln lässt dann kann man sich auch
im dreistelligen bereich hier und da
noch mal bedienen erleben wir gerade den
moment wo der wettbewerb unfair wird
koppeln sich da gerade zwei vereine ab
mit ihrer schier unerschöpflichen
finanziellen ressourcen
hätten uns ja die die regeln vor allem
dass die regeln des spiels also im
keller mit elf spielen also alle meiner
mannschaft gar nicht mehr auf dem platz
bringen so und deswegen ist ein
fußballspiel dass das geht ja nicht
darum wer hat die elf besten oder
spektakulärsten spieler auf dem platz es
geht darum wer macht aus dem wasser da
zusammen hat das beste und wer wäre
nutzt die spielfeldgröße am besten wer
für kleins im richtigen moment werbe und
webber ja macht am meisten aus seinen
eigenen möglichkeiten das gibt es ja
unglaublich wie möglich deshalb ist das
nicht unfaire sonst was das einfach nur
die aktuelle die normalität
aber wir haben ich weiß es wird
natürlich nicht so gesehen haben carla
stellt sich ja gibts ja unterschiedliche
aspekte mann kader zusammenstellen das
eine ist manhart bereits gerade zur
verfügung und das also ich finde es
wichtig dass man die verträge auch
respektiert mit den jungs die man hat
das heißt es ist ja klar der eine oder
andere spieler hat möglicherweise das
gefühl er möchte weggehen dann musste
erstmals finden dann verein finden der
sich mit uns dort mit uns einig und
solche dinge da gibt es andere spieler
die werden möglicherweise nicht genug
spielzeit bekommen im nächsten jahr so
aber de facto sind im moment ja noch da
und jetzt einfach dazu neue spieler
dazuzuholen das macht auch das macht gar
keinen sinn weil sie einen kader der
arbeit ein ganzes jahr zusammen und er
muss da muss auch schon auf eine
bestimmte art und weise funktionieren
das macht halt einfach nicht so viel
spaß wenn er 40 spieler hast und davon
sind dann
was ist das ungefähr 22 an jedem
wochenende
wirklich nicht gut drauf das zieht sich
das ganz schön langsam ja wenn sich dazu
durch zählt also und weil es jetzt nicht
so wie wir uns alle gründe sind alle
fein das sind alles spieler haben eine
absolut daseinsberechtigung hier aber zu
diesem kader noch was dazu zu holen
macht jetzt erstmal so gar keinen sinn
da wird mir immer erzählt wir brauchten
der mittelfeldspieler und wir brauchen
dort ist wir brauchen noch dazu wir
brauchen eine breite und hier und da das
kann durchaus sein aber wir haben schon
auch spieler die bisher aus
unterschiedlichen gründen ihr potenzial
noch nicht abrufen konnten so und die
jetzt in den in den fußstapfen treten
engine von genie banale mode von
spielern die noch hier sind aber diese
überholen können das ist absolut möglich
und es haben gestern mit habe allierten
18 jährige auf dem platz gehabt so wenn
wir jetzt ein mittelfeldspieler
verpflichtet hätten hätte der guest noch
nicht gespielt als beispiel
wahrscheinlich nicht gespielt und ich
schade wäre das denn gewesen wir haben
noch den 16 er war die ganze
vorbereitung ist dabei der husky gordon
das spiel jetzt wieder 23 wo auch
hingehört im moment aber das ist ein
riesentalent wäre wenn wir einfach immer
nur spieler dazuholen kriegen diese
spieler nie genug hier noch spielzeit
und da muss man einfach so die waage
finden wo man wirklich was braucht man
unbedingt um den nächsten schritt zu
machen und was kann man aus sich selbst
heraus entwickeln und während der
transferperiode beim einig über spiel
das zu viel sprechen kann sprich man
einfach unglaublich viel über wechseln
da das bei uns nicht so wahnsinnig da
bei uns nicht so wahnsinnig viel
passiert ist weiß ich schon dass man
dann denken wir wären eigentlich
ambitioniert und wollen gar nicht an
gott darauf wollte ich gar nicht genau
sich finzi ein sehr sympathischer club
dass sie sagen sie schaffen es mit den
spielern die sie da haben 16 18 jährige
sehr rand führt zumindest ebenbürtig
diesen beiden mannschaften paris und
mancity dazu begegnen lassen sie uns
einmal kurz über messi ist schneller ich
nicht weiter ganz geschichten natürlich
nicht stimmt da kann ja auch noch mal
kurz in kerkow 500 millionen in den
flieger gesetzt abramowitsch der
weisheit auch finanziell geht
er glaubt eine frage an sie als
fußballfan können sie sich mäßig
überhaupt in einem anderen trikot
vorstellen als in dem schönen barca
trikot mit dem jetzt alle 20 jahre ihnen
gefeiert und erlebt haben naja ist ja
auch irgendwie blau-rot glaube ich hinzu
wenn der ein oder andere variante
deswegen ist der unterschied zu müssen
wir in blau nicht so groß dass
strategisch fertig blutet ja so ein
betrag schwierig ist schwierig aber es
ist die situation und gerade über die
finanzen gesprochen und war es nur nach
offensichtlich hat im moment ein
bisschen probleme denn denn den
finanziellen bemühungen der der der der
jüngeren vergangenheit irgendwie noch
oder das eigene baden das im moment aus
und
das ist natürlich dann probleme und dann
kann man einfach nicht so weitermachen
wie bisher dann müssen müssen
entscheidung getroffen werden die
manchmal unpopulär sind das tut war so
ein moment und ja das in die zeit es ist
ganz ganz selten dass man irgendwo
hingeht aber richtig auf den putz haut
und dann nicht die rechnung dafür
bezahlen
würde sie eigentlich als trainer jungen
herr klopp wenn man jetzt diese paris
mannschaft sieht neymar messi im pub ist
also der erste trainer gedanken auf die
hätte ich auch mal bock in einer truppe
wir haben jetzt aber ganz sicher jemand
vergessen nicht wissen dass der eine
oder andere kann es auch noch bei paris
ja
nee also gedanken habe ich nicht das ist
auch nicht jeden tag glaube ich dass
reine honigschlecken natürlich sei das
schon auch mit charakteren die
auseinandersetzen muss und das ist auch
fein das sind alles tolle spieler
wahnsinn ich habe haben jetzt das
spiegel guckt am freitagabend haben sie
gegen presst 4 2 gewonnen so wenn man
die namen von paris hört das war nicht
dabei und messe nicht dabei die auch
schon mal trotzdem ziemlich in die
ziemlich gute aber natürlich erwarten
als nicht fußballer raten das muss man
80 geben und es waren 42 so also ein
fußballspiel wo die andere mannschaft
auch chancen hatte und tor erzielt hat
und dementsprechend ist das schöne am
fußball dass vom spiel kein mensch weiß
wer gewinnt und deswegen haben alle die
gleichen chancen manche weisen bessere
chancen für mich ein bisschen
schlechtere aber eine chance hat jeder
und das finde ich ziemlich geil an dem
spiel das ist ja das was wir alle am
fußball so lieben sprechen wir noch kurz
über ihre zukunft herr klopp ist ein
vertragliches 20 24 ist dann eigentlich
nach den neun jahren definitiv schluss
in liverpool oder können sie auch noch
weitergehen
die habe ich einfach gar nichts zu sagen
es wird jetzt noch so lange hin ist klar
es gibt die meisten bringen die meisten
trainer die jetzt im moment in amt und
würden sind wir die fragen wo du bist in
drei jahren würde sagen ja wenn erst
noch probier ich weiß wo ich im nächsten
zwei drei wochen bin so also deswegen
gibt es jetzt im moment gar nichts zu
sagen ist alles gut so wie es ist wir
sind genau am richtigen ort und wie
lange das so sein wird das hängt von ein
paar dinge ab die im moment noch nicht
wissen die eine nachfrage seiner
gestattet herr klopp der vertrag von
hansi flick der jetzt bundestrainer
geworden ist worüber wir uns alle sehr
freuen läuft auch bis zum sommer 2024
pause
ich habe ich dann gesagt falls für opel
stößt 2024 dann
sind ja urlaub das heißt hansi flick
urlaub wenn wir wenn sie wenn ich ihre
frage gestellt und ist praktisch fix
vertragen bis 225 laufen sagte an einem
einsatz in frage geben 224 bei mir gerne
anrufen alles klar das werden wir klären
herr klopp und wollen jetzt ganz am ende
noch mal kurz über gerd müller sprechen
einer der größten fußballer der
deutschen historie ist am vergangenen
sonntag im alter von 75 jahren
verstorben in dieser woche ist viel über
ihn gesprochen worden was sind ihre
gedanken zu gerd müller haben sie
bestimmte erinnerungen spiele oder tore
die sie immer bei sich tragen werden
wenn sie an ihn denken
ja klar das wm finale 1974 war sie im
jahre alt ist warum ein geburtstag
damals für ich hab's zusammen mit
freunden beim vater geguckt das tor habe
ich gesehen dass er auf lange von rainer
bonhof erzählt hat ich habe
wahrscheinlich fühlte sich an als ich
danach noch 67 800 andere tor von gerd
müller gesehen oder davor und um dieses
um die story um aber er war mit
sicherheit mit franz beckenbauer
zusammen die prägendste figur einer
fußballerischen entwicklung weil es
einfach meine beiden großen helden waren
in dieser altersgruppe ohne dass wir den
verein gespielt hätten dem mein herz
gehört hat aber bei der
nationalmannschaft war es natürlich die
beiden spieler und die geschichte von
gerd müller und was man über hin was ich
über ihn weiß ohne ihn jemals persönlich
getroffen zu haben ist die dass jeder
der ihn kannte über ihn nur in
höchsten tönen gesprochen hat einfach
ein haus gibt ein außergewöhnlich
bescheidener netter sympathischer kerl
der ja den den torinstinkt
möglicherweise ganz ganz alleine
erfunden hat gut vielleicht ein bisschen
auch von uwe seeler noch mit etwas
mitgekriegt hat und ja damit
unglaubliche dinge und veranstaltet hat
der bayern münchen mit sicherheit so
geprägt hat wie kaum jemand anders und
der leider die letzten paar jedes
lebensjahr nicht mehr so genießen konnte
wie wir uns allen gewünscht hätten und
aus eigener erfahrung kann man kann
nicht sagen dass dann manchmal hat man
auch als familienangehörige das gefühl
es ist jetzt auch okay wenn derjenige
geht und ich weiß nicht ob so war aber
wenn es so war dann kann ich nur sagen
dann weiß ich dass ich jetzt an einem
besseren ort ist und dass das was er
erreicht hat dann hoffe ich jetzt wieder
richtig genießen kann und auch wieder
als sie an alles erinnern kann herr
klopp das waren sehr bewegende worte zu
gerd müller den erfinder des torinstinkt
wie sie genannt haben sie sind ja der
erfinder von enormem an und ich habe
noch einmal auf die tasse geguckt fällt
ihnen auffällt ihnen der unterschied
auch wenn sie auf die tasse gucken und
wenn sie sich selbst aktuell im spiegel
anschauen mein bart ist grau es gibt
noch was anderes
ich weiß die brille die brille bull ist
weg so das ist jetzt regiert das dass
ich eigentlich ist total bremen hat aber
wahrscheinlich kann ich auch einfach
einmal aufklären so ich hatte mich hatte
ich trage brille seit meinem achten
lebensjahr bin jetzt 54 dass sie müssten
ungefähr 46 jahre sein sie hat mich nie
gestört ich habe mich total dran gewöhnt
das einzige problem war in den letzten
jahren konnten die brillengläser meine
sehschwäche nicht mehr richtig
korrigieren wer eine brille trägt weiß
dass der sinn und zweck einer brille ist
das genau das geschieht so also musste
ich mich darum kümmern was weil ich
nicht bereit war das einfach zu
akzeptieren weil meine ich nicht hab mir
war mit meiner sicht so dann gab es
alternativ dazu da habe ich mich darum
gekümmert und dann hat man festgestellt
dass ich dass das nicht richtig
funktioniert weil ich ein kleines
problem im auge habe und die lösung
dafür waren kleiner eingriff dieser
eingriff hat dazu geführt dass kein
lesern gewesen und sonst was hat dazu
geführt dass sich im moment ohne brille
sehr sehr sehr gut sehen
das heißt nicht dass ich nie wieder
brille tragen wäre das heißt nur dass
sie unter umständen normalen alltag
brauche ich keine mehr und es ist
tatsächlich finde habe ich immer nicht
dran gewöhnen ich finde mein gesicht
komisch ohne brille aber welche brille
aufsetzen mit fensterglas habe ich das
gefühl als ich durch eine glasscheibe
gucken und das nervt dann auch ich
brauche es ja nicht mehr und deshalb
trage ich im moment keine aber es gibt
die möglichkeit dass ich noch mal das
ist leicht verbessert werden kann durch
eine brille das aber nicht entschieden
und wenn das eintritt werde ich wieder
brille tragen wenn das nicht eintritt
werde ich keine mehr dran so das war's
und sonst schicken sie mir eine neue
tasche zog dann die cloud variante ohne
brille falls das dauerhaft als er ja das
ist ein problem für den verein ich habe
immer davor darüber informiert also das
war leider sitzt die ganzen schönen
artikel neu produziert
er glaubt die allerletzte frage heute
abend haben wir hier bild live bei
bild.de tschuldigung am premierentag die
große kanzler nacht scholz und laschet
sind zu gast die beiden die sich gerade
ein kopf an kopf rennen liefern jeweils
mit 22 prozent die grünen sind ein
bisschen abgefallen sebastian vettel hat
öffentlich gemacht dass er grün wählt
bei dieser bundestagswahl würden sie uns
auch verraten was sie wählen
nein in ordnung gibt es eine frage die
sie an einen der beiden heute abend
gerne stellen würden etwas was sie
interessiert als deutscher bürger was
der neue kanzler reißen soll
nein auch das nicht weil ich habe jetzt
nicht drüber nachgedacht und ich finde
über solche bin ich noch die gelegenheit
hätte diesen beiden menschen fragen zu
stellen sollte man vor ort um nachdenken
ich gehe mal davon aus dass beide sich
im klaren darüber sind dass sie in
extrem wenn sie wenn sie es denn
schaffen in extrem große fußstapfen
treten weil ich finde dass frau merkel
das außergewöhnlich gut gemacht hat und
wie immer im leben werden wir alle erst
feststellen wie gut wenn sie nicht mehr
da ist er war absolut nicht perfekt weil
das niemand sein kann in dem job und sie
hat wahrscheinlich alles richtig gemacht
weil man das weil das auch nicht geht im
leben aber sie hat unglaublich viel
richtig gemacht und sagt es über ganz
lange jahre das gefühl gegeben in guten
händen zu sein und ich persönlich bin ja
sehr dankbar dafür
obwohl ich damals nicht die cdu gewählt
habe das geht nämlich ich glaub das war
das schlusswort für heute nochmal
dankende worte an angela merkel die als
bundeskanzlerin im september ja abtritt
wir danken ihnen ganz herzlich für die
zeit die sie uns heute morgen gewidmet
haben dass sie die am premierentag von
bild live am start waren und falls die
nächsten sonntag auch eine halbe stunde
zeit haben wir sind jederzeit dankbar
dafür wenn wir sie mit ihrer art hier
bei uns bei bild live erleben dürfen so
streichen sie sich schon mal rot im
kalender hat das können wir vergessen